diga uma coisa a você hoje eu sou um
cara Graças a Deus tudo deu certo ainda
tenho minhas metes meu plano de vida a
bater mas eu mudei a minha vida e hoje
eu sou um cara que eu tenho um padrão de
vida que eu adoro que eu amo que eu
nunca quero perder mas não importa
quanto dinheiro você quer na sua conta
você bota o cartão fica sem aguardando
resposta autorizando com 70 pessoas
atrás botando pressão meu amigo negócio
demorando autorizar você começa a dar
desculpa não é porque o sinal aqui
dentro é mercado é muito metal né muita
né então fica meio isso aqui é normal
galera começa a olhar
parece que o cara não tá com essa bola
toda não eita força o Kondzilla hein até
o menino do Salgadinho mamãe
Ei bebê agora também quando diz assim
vai querer mancho parece que Jesus
passou a mão na cabeça da gente falou
porque te preocupas